thank you Bill it's of course a pleasure
to be here again I was here if just a
few few years ago actually does anyone
hear them no cold [ __ ] right the end
Kyle Turri kyun advising me the lasses
is not here anymore so anyway it's good
to good to come back i'm looking forward
to spending our interesting remainder of
the day and tomorrow morning i'm here as
as well so when I decided build invited
me he I gave him a few topics that I
could talk about and he he chose this
one which and which is one that I
actually haven't really given a talk
about yet before because usually when I
get invited place as they want to hear
something that's specifically about
North America but we do a lot of work on
other other parts of the world as well
so I'm going to be covering quite a bit
of the world today and but because this
is the first time I've given this I'm
going to be as surprised as you when I
see what's on the next slide because I
did I put this together and rather
rather a hurry because of all sorts of
other things going on but there's some
it's a pretty large group of people we
have haven't Lamont who have been
working on aspects of decayed or
variability for said for several years
now and there's some they're all this
list that they're callin wenchang and
sloan three PhD students whose thesis
touch on various aspects of this column
has already graduated wenchang and Sloan
are still there and also a load of
people at the International Research
Institute for climate and society which
is on the Lamont campus as well okay and
mostly funded by noah NSF and Department
of Energy the no reward is unfortunately
terminating despite the success of three
years of research and fifty papers they
terminated the program and please do not
ask me of my opinions about Noah so on
we go so before I get on to the the
topic of decayed or variability I don't
want to be accused of
talking about thinking variability
matters and climate change does not
matter so let's get that out of them out
of the way right now Hydra climate
around the world is going to change as a
result of rising greenhouse gases and
this has been known for several years
now going but it really bit it was the
most recent IPCC the IPCC assessment
report for based on see map three that
this really started coming out and
getting a lot of attention on top of all
the tenth attention that was being paid
to temperature changes and the new one
that is we coming out soon ar5 and based
on seen it five the results are
essentially very very much the same as
what you get from seem it three and the
global patterns are shown here in in
terms of precipitation minus
evaporations that's the net flux of
water at the at the surface of the
surface of the earth and the map on the
left is I believe these are seemeth
these are seamen five results the map on
the left shows what p minus een is now
together with lower tropospheric flow
fields the wet itcz and monsoon all
regions the very dry subtropics and
wetter regions in the high latitudes and
you can see the flow converging from the
trade winds into the wet tropical
regions and you can see the flow
diverging away from the dry subtropics
and converging again into the into the
higher latitudes that transport of water
vapor explains why we have this banded
structure of p minus e around the world
and then the one on the right is the
change averaged across a whole load of
these models for the next two decades
period relative to the second half of
the 20th century and you can see that
the first order you will get areas that
are already dry become drier areas that
are already wet become wetter so the
subtropics dry and a deep tropics and
higher latitudes get wetter less obvious
there but is you can also is that
there's an a poet expansion of
subtropical dry zones as the storm
tracks retreat poleward the Hadley cell
expands and so on that's why is the
models project that will happen that's a
multi-model mean so you don't see any
real component of natural variability
there that's just the radiatively force
component so there's a couple of
questions that immediately come to mind
from that is is this happening is this a
change that is already underway and even
if it is already underway how important
of these hydro climate changes relative
to the variability that will happen on
these timescales so the decayed all very
the decayed or variability that just
occurs from natural oscillations of the
of the climate system so that's pretty
hard to tell whether it's happening now
when you look at precipitation trends
I've plotted this is all based on gpcc
station data and there are two different
trends there one at the bottom is 1979
to 2007 that's a time period that is
often used post 1979 because of the 1979
is kind at the beginning at the
satellite era it is the beginning of the
satellite here of precipitation and many
re analyses begin in 1979 like the ECMWF
one so that's often used as a time time
and if you look at the trends over there
you see that there's a considerable
drying of western North America for
example that has occurred since 1979 and
that was one thing that was in the
article in the new york times today but
then if you look at the longer period
1901 to 2007 you don't see that in in
the southwest so over a very long time
scaled we don't you don't really see
much evidence that Southwest North
America actually is drying like the
models predict it should do but then
over the shorter period you find that
you do see it drying well the reason for
that is that when you're looking at
these long trends you are it's different
sampling of the decayed or variability
that is giving you different trend
patterns depending on when you start the
data look at the Sahel region of Africa
for example where you've got a wedding
trend since nineteen
99 but if you look at the whole period
you've got a drying trend trend there
again that's just because of different
sampling of the natural decato
variability okay so what we're going to
talk about now is for the rest of talk
is this decayed or variability and in
one little bit more climate change comes
in but mostly I'm just going to talk
about natural decay debility so to my
mind the only the reasons for being
concerned with decayed or variability
are it has to be clear to anyone who's
old enough to live through it it has I
mean it has to be clear in your
day-to-day life that this has actually
happened and it should not require any
fancy statistics to see it so if you can
only see this through some fancy
singular spectrum analysis then forget
about it it's not going to matter for
anything and it should have some pretty
clear consequences to the people who are
actually living through it that turns
out to be true for much of the world i
remember when i arrived here in 1983 my
advice i was a guess and my advisors
were david rind and jim hansen and one
of the things that Jim that Dave rind
said to me in like the first like month
of of being there was that in New York
City where we were and where I still
live there's about you know since like
the early 1970s there's been about a
twenty five percent increase in
precipitation relative to the earlier
part of the 20th century and I'm going
to get back to that because we will talk
about that and that actually really
really struck me to that that that was
the case and I'm rather glad that
eventually some thirty years later we
actually said we actually did look at
that problem but it's something that
everyone who is old enough I mean I to
New York in 1983 so it was too late but
someone like David or anyone else who is
a New York City resident is old enough
knows that it's just was obvious that if
you lived through it that it suddenly
got wetter in in the early 1970s and
there
some other common examples as well so so
based on this principle that if it has
to be if it's good if it's a worth
analyzing and of importance then it's
got to be obvious the analysis that will
proceed will be entirely based only on
maps for particular times and time
series and some model simulations and
some observations but all based on maps
and time series based on sheer
simplicity and this is the the Americas
part of this is going to be appearing in
a book chapter that will be published
late later this year so two parts of
north of North America will talk about
and then northeast Brazil the southern
part of South America the Mediterranean
East Africa so no no all I mean no no
all I mean by all I mean by that is some
decades are distinctly different from
other decades it doesn't have to have a
particular peak in the spectrum it could
come about from rectified interannual
variability but deck a a deck an average
over one decade is going to be notably
different from an average over other
decades it's a very impress ice
definition but it doesn't have to refer
to a spectral peak so its variability
not necessarily an oscillation okay so
this is these are all pictures of
decayed or variability and we will get
to them bit by bit you can guess as to
where to where they are right now I
think the one on the top left is pretty
obvious that's the Colorado River there
it is and Mexico it will be included in
this discussion as well and this is
where we are as of now this is the
drought monitor on februari 11 2014 it
comes out every Thursday so that's last
thursday's and as you know California is
going through
of the more severe droughts that it's
had within within the last century or
more but that is part of a general
drought that is affecting pretty much
everywhere west of the Mississippi River
in fact and though not in California
much of the southwestern part of the
United States has actually been in
drought since the 97 98 El Nino so the
southwestern drought is now reaching
about 14 years in length now so that
would classify as decayed or variability
okay so one of the main tools we use for
analyzing this kind of thing are these
extensive series of climate model
simulations that we do at Lomond these
have always historically being done with
the old ncar CCM 3 which is a model of
1998 vintage and it turns out to be
particularly good in the Americas we're
now trying to decommission it and
replace it with cam 5.3 and we will see
whether that is a as performs as well as
simulating America's hydro climate
variability as CCM three because the
intervening end car models all the cams
to and cams 123 were not as good as CCM
3 which is why we stuck with CCM 3 so
all of these simulations begin in 1856
when sea surface temperature
observations begin we always do
16-member ensembles they go up through
the end of 2012 right now we update them
in about februari march as soon as the
Hadley center releases December of the
previous year's sea surface temperature
which you haven't done yet for last year
different atmospheric initial conditions
so we end up with 16 member ensembles
and the basic ensemble is global sea
surface temperature forcing so the
atmosphere model sees the sea surface
temperature histories absolutely
everywhere and then we do other ones
where we only change the sea surface
temperatures in tropical Pacific or the
tropical Atlantic or all the tropics and
so on and so on and so forth
and what I'm showing here actually is a
comparison between the soil moisture in
the model which is the blue curve in the
top and the shading around it is the
plus minus two standard deviation of the
ensemble spread and then the black curve
there is the soil moisture as simulated
by the Vic land surface hydrology model
at the University of Washington where
they took a land surface model and they
force that within observed temperature
and precipitation so they're taking the
observed meteorology and computing the
soil moisture from that so that's like
as good as we can get for observed soil
moisture and you can see that there's a
broad sweep there in which the model is
capturing these decayed all variations
especially it it's very wet decades in
the 1980s and 1990s and then the dry
period since then dry a period in in the
1950s and so on and some of the year to
year Peaks are being captured there as
well and you can see from the picture
below that much of that is actually
being dictated by the tropical Pacific
sea surface temperatures so that's not
the only story in for the southwestern
part of North America but the tropical
Pacific is by far the biggest part
giving the variability on the
interannual time scales and then going
out to these decade to decade swings as
well previously we've tended to show
these pictures for precipitation but
this one is directly more hydrologically
relevant in that is actually for soil
moisture it's it should be is not on
these I can tell you sorry who was the
question ah they're about point five
what's a correlation color
so it's about twenty-five percent of the
variance which is pretty high for these
kinds of things there's only about one
place in the world in the term I that
you can actually get about that get
above that so it means about a quarter
of the variance of precipitation if you
did it for precipitation or soil
moisture in that region is ocean forced
there's a that has a higher correlation
than south west north america south west
north america is one of the places where
the hydro climber is most closely
controlled by by the oceans South East
South America would be another one if
you do it around here it's essentially
where we are right now in the Northeast
is essentially zero so it's not you know
that internal atmospheric variability
gives you the other three quarters okay
so then this one is shifting from the
southwest to to the Great Plains here
actually the correlation coefficient is
all is would be is almost as high you're
basically getting the same story in the
the globe most of what the global oceans
are doing is actually coming from the
tropical Pacific in the Great Plains too
so if you look at take these soil
moisture maps I soil moisture either for
the the observed one which is the Vic
reconstructed one or for the model which
is the one at the bottom so that's the
ensemble mean and correlate them with
sea surface temperatures around the
world then you can see that big pit big
tropical Pacific El Nino like when it's
an El Nino conditions within the
tropical Pacific Ocean soil moisture in
the southwestern United States tends to
be high and the model just makes that by
it's an ensemble means of it isolates
the sea surface temperature force
component just beefs up that correlation
a little bit higher anything going on in
the in the Atlantic Ocean is rather not
very
obvious in here there's seem to be
perhaps the Atlantic is a little bit
more influential in the southern parts
of the plains and northern Mexico but
for this particular region in southwest
u.s. that's not going to be a big pot
big part of it the only we've done it we
have it all for rainfall as well
rainfall actually works slightly better
there's a better you can reproduce the
rainfall a bit better than soil moisture
but that could be because soil moisture
data is on of actually unavailable so
the soil moisture is actually being
computed by a hydrology model force with
observed meteorology and soil moisture
is a touchy field in climate models
because models have all sorts of
different depths of soil moisture so I'm
putting soil moisture there because very
often if you show it in precipitation
someone who works in water resources
will say oh that's very well you can do
a precipitation but what about soil
moisture so I wanted to go dxa actually
if you do do it in soil moisture it does
work you could do it with runoff as well
but the precipitation works you can
simulate that a little bit better okay
so to look at some different decades two
very different decades in the American
West were the 1930s and the 1990s so the
30s were of course the dust bowl drought
and then the 1990s were about the
wettest decade of the 20th century if we
look back and tree ring records going
back hundreds of years the 1980s and
1990s stand out as perhaps about the
wettest decade in a in a millennium in
Western North America that's a bit
ironic because those were also two
decades of days those were the two
decades of phenomenal population growth
in the southwestern part of the United
States as well I mean as and that was no
doubt made a lot easier by the fact that
there was abundant water resources
during those two decades so the top maps
showed a seesaw
temperature for those two and you can
see that in the 1930s the global warming
signal is there you know you can see
that the in the latter decade it's just
warmer everywhere in the earlier decade
you can see this very weak la ninia like
state that exists in the tropical
Pacific Ocean at that time and the the
Atlantic was a little bit warm at that
time too we now know from all this
modeling that that's an ideal state to
set up a precipitated set up dry over
western North America the drought that
occurred during the Dust Bowl was that
one there which was centered around
about in the central plains going up
into the into the northern plains it was
knocked down in southwest and then the
lower left there is what the model
produces for the same thing with global
sea surface temperature forcing so it's
a little bit too far south of where it
actually should be and going down into
Mexico we feel we know why that is there
because this one this model does not
include dust aerosols when we redid
these simulations with a model with
interactive dust and allowed the dust
storms to be generated that moves the
drought it intensifies the drought but
it also moves to drought north with the
movement of the dust so in the 1930s it
unique amongst North American droughts
the dust played an added feedback so we
feel some of that difference is
explainable by contrast in the 1990s
this was a decade which was overall El
Nino like so you have a big fat warm
anomaly in the tropical Pacific and this
was over all wet so you can see for the
model it kind of just reverses the
pattern that it had in the 1930s but wet
across the pretty much the entire North
American continent and that matches
reasonably well what actually happened
in the 1990s so these decades and just
like the El Ninos and Lonnie Nia's on
the year-to-year basis can influence
precipitation over North America when
you look at these decade to decade
differences that have occurred over the
20th century it's also the Trog the
lower frequency part of the tropical
Pacific
variability that is explaining that okay
so move on to the next area which is the
Northeast North America and the
motivation for doing this was the water
supply of New York City which we did get
a small amount of money to look at
drought vulnerability and climate change
in in in the Northeast so New York City
draws its water from the Catskill
Mountains which are where's the thing on
here ah there they are New York City's
down here and the Catskill Mountains are
about a hundred miles northwest of New
York City the first water supply came
from the Croton watershed which is in
suburban parts of area north of New York
here and then in the early part of the
20th century this was not enough they
developed the Catskill system which
collects water from both the Hudson
watershed and the Delaware watershed
sending it in akwa in aqueducts all the
way down through to the Croton watershed
and down to the city a phenomenally
impressive feat of engineering so this
is the D Ashokan reservoir in the
Catskills and that's a relatively recent
photograph which is why it's looking
very nice and full because it they've an
abundant amount of water in that right
now and this is just here this is
actually the new Croton dam at the
bottom of the new Croton reservoir here
which is one of the most Sun that almost
the most southerly reservoir there's a
there's the old croton aqueduct and now
the new croton aqueduct which comes down
from that I took that photograph myself
it's just an amazingly beautiful piece
of engineering this thing here it's like
that was built around 1920s so this is
that remember what david ryan told me
when I was a graduate student about that
jump in precipitation that occurred in
New York City in the early 1970s when it
turns out it wasn't just New York City
it was the whole it was also occurred
over the Catskill Mountains
and much of the much of the eastern part
of the United States as well so this is
rain gauge data going back to 1900 the
drought the exercises the attentions of
the water engineers in New York City is
one that occurred in from that 1962 to
1966 it was pretty much a year-round
drought and there's no seasonal cycle of
rainfall around here in you know every
season pretty much gets the same and
that drought occurred in pretty much
every season in in the nine in the 1960s
and and then immediately not quite
immediately after that the around about
the early 1970s you had this enormous
jump in rain and and snow and we've been
living in that high precipitation part
ever since it hasn't got ever gone back
to what it was before then so they
nonetheless we had after we published
this paper last year and there was a
companion paper where we looked at a
500-year tree-ring record for the hudson
valley and the Catskills which some of
my colleagues at the tree-ring lab at
lamont did and that shows that actually
this is part of a 500 year long wedding
trend and the head of the new york city
water supply somehow found out about
these papers and invited me in neil
pedersson the tree-ring guide to the
water headquarters at the kensic oh damn
to talk to the engineers and the people
in charge of inter basin water transfers
with the Delaware River and so on
because they're under a tremendous
amount of pressure given this wet to run
the reservoirs more empty the rafting
industry wants more water in the rivers
in the Catskills the sports fishing
industry wants more water in the rivers
the communities want the dams less the
reservoirs less full for flood control
especially after Hurricane Irene so the
city is under tremendous pressure to
release more water and what so we talked
about this and we talked about the 60s
the sixties drought and how
we have no we can't say why that
happened at all and that this is like a
part of a long-term wetting trended we
also can't really explain it doesn't fit
into ocean forcing or anything like that
and the head of the water supply was
absolutely delighted with this because
it this was like all he needed to know
in order to continue planning for
drought because they live in the city
lives in fear that this something like
this is going to come in going to come
back it's much warmer now than it was
then water demand has gone up a lot than
that all they needed to know was this
was an entirely unpredictable event that
it could begin tomorrow and you would
never have no advance warning and that
was enough that they would not do make
any decision to run the reservoirs more
empty than they they currently are so
that turned out to be rather actionable
yeah
um well that wouldn't I mean it wouldn't
around a city because that's all very
tightly controlled right but up further
up beyond the I mean it's you can it
definitely has i mean because we did as
part of the work there we did a redid a
flow reconstruction of the Hudson River
Valley North the hudson river north of
albany and you can definitely see in
that that the float did go up yeah and
the flows has apparently been increasing
for 500 years so this wetting that
occurred in the early nineteen 1970s and
we did the same thing we looked a few
weather the climate model force by
observed SSTs could reproduce the 60s
drought and the shift to wetter it can't
we look to see whether the seam it five
seem at three models when you put in
changes in radiative forcing and
increasing co2 do they make it wetter no
they don't they make it only very very
very slightly wetter around here so
there was no evidence that this was in
any way ocean for store radiatively
force but there was like this intriguing
piece of evidence that i came across
almost by chance that at that time in
the early 1970s there was a
strengthening of the storm track across
pretty much the whole North Pacific
North America and North Atlantic so
Edmund Chang wrote a paper about this in
2002 where he showed this in Radian n
separate out-of-stater if you just do
the first eof of Eddie Meridian or
velocity variance see not pi pass
filtered you find that there's a
strengthening of the whole Pacific North
America Atlantic storm track and he
wrote in that paper that's the chang and
foo one that this must be a problem with
the reanalysis so then he teamed up with
Neely harnack who she became a postdoc
of mine just after that and they looked
at it again and they thought well let's
find out what's wrong with the
reanalysis and they went back to the
radiosonde data trying to find out
something that caused an artificial
strengthening of the storm track india
early 1970s and they found that it's
just in the raid it's in the radiosonde
data those didn't seem to be anything
wrong with the radiosonde data it wasn't
a reanalysis product it could just look
at it in the raw radiosonde data so they
said it must be something that is
actually real so and then I found if you
actually just compute a measure of the
reanalysis ed upper tropospheric
meridian or velocity variance right over
the Catskill Mountains and compare it
with precipitation over the Catskill
Mountains they match each other quite
well and you can see an earlier period
the 60s drought is in here and then in
the early 1970s it's mostly positive sin
since then that's actually right over
the Catskill Mountains and then the maps
if you just take the later period minus
the earlier period and this is upper
tropospheric Meridian velocity variance
you see a positive over here over the
Pacific over North America over the
Atlantic spring fall and then what these
pictures are the same thing that now
they're taken from the 20th century
reanalysis now that's important because
the 20th century reanalysis from Gil
comp OD University of Colorado it's a
NOAA product only use a surface pressure
data it does not use radiosonde data or
anything else like that it only uses
surface pressure and you find this
strengthening in the surface pressure
data to its mirror muted version of what
you find in the full rig analysis but
it's there so it appears in the
reanalysis it appears in the radiosonde
data and it appears in surface pressure
data and it looks like the same pattern
it's the Pacific the Atlantic and the
storm track over North America the whole
hemispheric storm track strengthening in
the early 1970s and then staying that
strong up to now and that seems to have
had a precipitation impact and in the
northeastern United States now that
doesn't line up with any of the other
regime shifts we we know of its before
the 1976 Pacific shift it does correlate
with the
up the beginning of the upward trend in
North Atlantic Oscillation but as the
the nao then went started trending in
the opposite direction in the late 1990s
where as this storm track strengthening
just continued however it's also not the
nao because the nao induces no storm
track variability over the northeastern
US it's storm track variability is over
the eastern part of the Atlantic and and
Europe so it's not related to its not
directly related to the nao it's some
other type of phenomenon that seems to
be no one pays any attention to it it
seems to be sort of the the eccentric
uncle of the climate family but I would
be very curious if anyone can explain
what this kind of thing is my hunch is
that this is just internal decayed or
variability of the atmosphere working
entirely on its own and but I certainly
can't can't prove that but we're trying
to look now by running just an
atmosphere model entirely on its own for
10,000 years and see whether we can get
multi-decade or variability of an
atmospheric storm track that doesn't
involve the ocean or anything else and
we'll see okay so next northeast Brazil
the sertao northeast Brazil is a climate
oddity because it's about the one of the
few areas in the world where you have a
semi arid area to the west of a warm
tropical ocean and it's like it's a tiny
little corner right at the edge of
Northeast Brazil and it's got a little
the right along the coast there's some
nice wet areas but if you go inland it
becomes it's like a real desert if
you've ever been there I was able to go
there several several years ago and it
really is quite a remarkable area and it
is it about the poorest area of Brazil
and it's been endlessly producing and
still does rural migrants to the cities
of Northeast Brazil and to Mike and to
southeastern into the southern
industrial parts of Brazil as well
so when you look at precipitation in
this area 1900 on again it's gpcc and
put that together with what the model
producers with global sea surface
temperature forcing we do really rather
well here and you can see that there is
a drought here say for example in the
late 70s early 80s a very wet period in
the 1920s and a lot else going on as
well but if you take the tropical
Pacific sea surface temperature forcing
only one then there's no matchup between
the model and the and the observations
in this case I've plotted the individual
ensemble members as these little thin
lines I didn't plot to spread as shading
and the reason I did that is because
this they they with global sea surface
temperature forcing they move so closely
together each ensemble member like each
ensemble member in the early 1980s
produces this really severe drought so
they're so tightly you can actually plot
them you know and it doesn't look like a
big bunch of spaghetti the ocean control
is so strong in this tropical region but
apparently it's not coming from the
tropical Pacific because the tropical
Pacific on its own doesn't do very well
this has been noticed before by many
people Alessandra Jenny near the IR I
did this from my had a picture like this
from 1952 2000 so we were because we
have these much longer atmosphere model
runs we were able to extend this back to
1900 actually we can extend it back even
further to the 1850s because fortaleza
the big city in Northeast Brazil has a
rain gauge that looks reliable that goes
back at least to the 1860s but there's
just like the one there this is a
collection of rain gauges from 1900 now
and of course this actually was one of
the first things that people noticed in
seasonal interannual prediction they
were a load of pay papers by Stefan
hasten wrath and maura and shukla in in
the 1980s
that showed this link between Northeast
Brazil and the tropical Atlantic and
when you take the observed precipitation
in in this region and this is a
regression these are not correlation
coefficient so this is actually in units
of Kelvin or something like that or
maybe it's standardized or whatever but
when it's wet in Northeast Brazil which
is this region here you have this dipole
of sea surface temperatures across the
tropical Atlantis when it's wet it's
warm in the South when it's and cold in
the north so this is shifting the CD
itcz down to which normally is sitting
north of northeast Brazil when it's warm
in the South Atlantic the itcz takes
them all is located further to the south
and that's what brings heavy rains to
northeastern Brazil and in the model you
get that as well and you can see that
there is a some connection to the
tropical Pacific Ocean but apparently
from what we see that we can't simulate
as well unless we have deer with only
two Pacific it's this Atlantic influence
that is that is doing that its strong
that is earned a strong one there so the
maps for this case so the 1920s very wet
time this is the sea surface temperature
just averaged out during the pluvial of
the early mid 1920s and you can see the
dipole in the tropical Atlantic there
and then the about the most severe
drought of the 20th century was in the
late 70s to early 80s there it is and
you can see the opposite sign sea
surface temperature anomaly in the in
the Atlantic Ocean the Pacific is kind
of doing the same thing in boast of both
of those cases so the fact that the
precipitation is quite different this is
the model renditions of the same thing
observations and model the fact that
they're doing different things in
Northeast Brazil despite both being warm
in the tropical Pacific is because this
Atlantic dipole is the dominant
influence there so the previous work on
this in Northeast Brazil
really been looking at seasonal
interannual prediction but when we look
at the decadal variations which are
really quite strong in that region we're
seeing the same thing again it's the
decayed or variability of the tropical
Atlantic sea surface temperatures that
are that are controlling that okay so
one two three four fourth area southie
this is the last one of the American so
South East South America these are
pictures of the the other Dust Bowl the
lesser-known Dust Bowl the nineteen the
pampers 1930s Dust Bowl and there was a
period of severe wind erosion that
occurred in Argentine in southern Brazil
Argentina Uruguay in the 1930s at
exactly the same time as that was
occurring in north in North America this
was not at that time an agriculturally
intensive area but it was ranched there
was a little little bit of agriculture
there hasn't been a lot written about
this but it does appear in the you can
see this event in the Antarctic ice core
because there's a big slug of dust
deposition that I believe has been
traced to the Pampers that occurs around
about the 1930s but there's quite a bit
more work being done and these are
pictures taken from a paper boom trip
aldi weather geomorphologist who has
been dating these these what are now
fossilized dunes down there these people
seem quite happy about the situation so
this is the precipitation history that
you get from South East South America
the observed one is black and you see
that this actually doesn't look totally
different to the catskill mountains it's
got it went through a wetting in the mid
early mid 1970s and it stayed wet ever
since this is the drought that occurred
in the 1930s this this is when the
Pampers bust Dust Bowl occurred
this wet trend that has has occurred is
important in your daily life because as
in your daily life because this has
allowed a phenomenal expansion of
agriculture in Argentina Brazil and
Uruguay into what were formerly
semi-arid areas that have now because of
this wet trend essentially becomes sub
humid and this has become one of the
main producers of soybeans for the world
a lot mostly soybeans are actually being
exported to Asia now but it's it's a key
part of the of the global agricultural
food supply that we did not have before
the 1970s this is all rain-fed
agriculture they are not irrigating
there and they would not have been able
to do this before before the 1970s but
now now they are and the question that
comes up down there is is this is this
wet trend going to continue obviously
the farmers want this twedt trend to
continue Argentina and Uruguay and
Brazil want this wet trend to continue
because this is this has been great for
their economy but in order to work that
out you've got to come up with some some
explanation for why it's happening and
it does remain a bit of a mystery as you
can see our model the blue one does get
a wet period out here in the 70s and 80s
but our model and other models too then
it starts going dry after 19 after 1998
and the reason for that is is as I'll
show you in a bit is is that that shift
between this dryer period in the middle
of the century and this wet period over
here was again related to sea surface
temperatures partly that's the warmth of
the warm El Nino light conditions in the
78 in the late 70s 80s and 90s and and
partly it's the Atlantic multidecadal
oscillation that expresses an influence
down down here but Enzo and the
IMO started shifting in the late
yeah that helps but so what's the role
of mountains of it you checked out west
coast drive is that changed entirely
during the West years well that that
reputation so it's dry because it's in a
rain shadow if you far enough south down
here so well these anomalies are a
little bit north of that the main source
of moisture for these regions is
actually it's winds that are coming
through the Amazon and heading south
because they can't get moisture from the
Pacific as the mountains so their
moisture supply is coming from the
Atlantic and that's what the waves are
modulating that amount of moisture
supply from the Atlantic okay but we
can't despite the influence of you know
this this the Atlantic and the Pacific
and the ozone depletion we still can't
explain why it's still staying wet there
so is that another case of just
fortunate atmospheric variability
continuing it I don't know so um a
little bit about the Pacific decadal and
n so this is a lot of pictures but it's
relatively simple like all of this so
these are sea surface temperature over
the ocean and precipitation anomalies
over the land composited for the warm
phase of the Pacific decadal oscillation
the cold phase and then these ones are
the warm phase of Nino 34 and the cold
phase of Nino 34 so these are really
emphasizing interannual variability
these are emphasizing de kadel
variability ok and what I want to point
out is just how similar these are so a
warm el nino event has a precipitation
pattern over the americas wet dry wet
dry very similar to what a warm Pacific
decadal oscillation does warm dry wet
dry wet
I and there are many similarities in
other parts of the of the world too
including over over Africa and then over
here is the model version of exactly the
same the model was run over exactly the
same time period so we can do the same
compositing and the model can reproduce
that that kind of thing so I don't think
I just don't want to think there's
anything different to the Pacific
decadal oscillation other than n so it's
just a low frequency VIP realization of
the El Nino Southern Oscillation and
it's a first-order it's precipitation
anomalies are just the same as what you
get out of El Nino and La Nina events so
the decayed or very the physical origin
of this decade or variability is really
not different and the physical
expression of it is really not different
to what that what the tropical Pacific
does to the world on just a day on a
year-to-year season to season
year-to-year basis so that's simple and
it's a worthwhile it's a useful
simplification I think okay eastern
Mediterranean so in this case this is
Syria yeah going to get back to that
Syria the Mediterranean went through a
late 20th century drying trend that has
ameliorated a little bit but this is the
three decades over which it was the
worst from the early 60s the strongest
drying trend from the early 60s to the
1990s based on uea precipitation data
and this was very widespread spaying
North Africa Italy the whole northern
shore of the Mediterranean and over
there into the Middle East and the
question there as well is this decay is
this also decayed or variability or is
there some evidence that this is is due
to climate change because if you if you
remember the first map I showed you the
Mediterranean is one region where the
models predict there will be a
significant amount of drying due to
rising greenhouse gases well if you look
at the first pattern of eof I'm sorry
that's an eof
it's complicated analysis so I'm
violating my rule for this talk but
anyway this is the the dominant pattern
of precipitation variability in the
Mediterranean section in the
Mediterranean sector and it looks very
much like the drying trend that I just
showed that I just showed you it's the
spatial pattern is extremely similar
there's a difference in Israel Jordan
parts of Syria which is wet for the when
the rest is dry whereas the observed
drying trend was dry in this region and
and over there and this this explains
about twenty five percent of the total
variance so what is that pattern well
that is the precipitation a pattern
precipitation associated with the North
Atlantic Oscillation so the North
Atlantic Oscillation is leading modes of
absolute variability in the North
Atlantic sector and in its positive
state it creates high pressure there's a
sea level pressure oh over in the Azores
region and over the Mediterranean region
and if you look at the time series of
the North Atlantic Oscillation going
back to 1900 up to 2000 and something or
other and you compare that with the time
series of that first pattern of
variability of precipitation over the
Mediterranean they match each other
extremely well so the precipitation has
been inverted here so this was the 60s
to 90s trend towards a positive nao that
went along with drying in the
Mediterranean and then some amelioration
of that recently so the precipitation in
this region is very very strongly
controlled by this North Atlantic
Oscillation which is a hugely powerful
mode of natural variability internally
routed in atmospheric dynamics so is all
that that is going on so this is a
correlation of rain gauge data with the
nao index so when the nao is positive
you have reduced precipitation across
this whole region but then increase
precipitation in Israel Jordan Egypt
not as much precipitation there at all I
think I've made the point about the nao
control on Mediterranean precipitation
so how would we then try to work out
whether that explains everything that
has occurred in Mediterranean
precipitation over 220 over the last
several decades there are a number of
ways of doing that if you're just going
to be using data one thing to do is you
can just project it on some index of
force change like global mean surface
air temperature there are complicated
ways involving signal noise eof and then
another way of doing it is projecting
precipitation on time series of
greenhouse gas radiative forcing which
is this black line here so we did all
three and they all come back with
essentially the same the same result and
that is like this so these go up please
do go up a bit more recently through
2003 for this is again the total trend
over the last four decades this is this
is when you've just regress on the index
of greenhouse gas increases this is that
first eof I showed you so this is the
nao pattern of variability this then is
the difference between the total and
this so this so if you take away from
the total the part that correlates with
the increase in greenhouse gases you
should end up with a part that looks
like natural variability so that
hopefully should look like this and it
does but what you see here and what is
it is interesting is that the the the
part of the total trend over here in the
eastern Mediterranean the drying cannot
be explained in terms of the nao
variability because the nao actually
when it goes negative but it goes
positive the nao makes the eat that part
of the eastern Mediterranean where and
that part of the eastern Mediterranean
has been drawing so what this analysis
does and it does the same if you do the
signal noise eof and however you do it
it all comes back the same way that
drying that has occurred in the eastern
part of the Mediterranean is a response
to rising greenhouse gases the drying
that occurred in Spain Italy and various
in other parts of regions is more evenly
split split between natural variability
and greenhouse gas increase but in the
Mediterranean it's dominated by the rise
in greenhouse gases so now we've got to
one example we're on our example number
five or something where it does seem
that climate change is appearing and
what we're seeing is not just decade or
variability to change to just re plot
that in terms of percent this over here
in the eastern Mediterranean is about a
fifteen percent reduction in in
precipitation which is quite significant
so Syria is of course of tremendous
concern right now if you look at all
Syria precipitation there is a steady
decline it's not that impressive but
they had a very severe drought in two
thousand six seven eight around about
that period and this shows up in there
aren't many rain gauge data available in
in Syria but here are two of them where
it shows up this seems to be a funny
data point out here two of them where it
seems to show up down here so this was
kind of as severe as any that had
occurred before especially in terms of
three years running there was something
like that that happened in late 1950s
but since then Syria has a much larger
population and also in the intervening
decades there was a decision by the
Assad regime to make Syria a food
independent country and it expanded its
agricultural sector to trying to grow
all of its own food it became more
dependent on its agricultural economy in
this intervening years at the same time
as its population grew et cetera etc and
Tom Friedman in the New York Times wrote
an article last year to nose 2012 where
he pointed
they're the role the possible role of
climate change in in in night igniting
some of the Arab revolts that occurred
and he has a film that's going to be
coming out about this soon or a TV show
that's kept going to be coming out about
this soon there seems to be no doubt
about this because the time the
newspapers were absolutely full of
stories of farmers and their families in
the northern part of Syria leaving their
homes and as the stories when you know
we can survive one year of drought we
can survive maybe two but if it gets to
three we have no there's nothing that we
have no reserves left we have to leave
and they did and working with an
undergraduate at Columbia who had
actually traveled in the region the year
before last and she put together this
this plot from data that you know
readily available data about migration
going so this is a timeline of events so
the first thing that happened in Syria
was the Iraq war and then Syria became
swamped with refugees from Iraq they
reached about one and a half million by
the time you got to 2010 and they have
not returned I suppose they have been
returning recently but by the time the
war began in Syria they had not and then
the number of refugees from the northern
part of Syria so internal Syrian
refugees to the cities of Syria equal to
that by the time you got through to 2010
so it was over a million and those
numbers come from you the United Nations
and various other relief organizations
that were working working on those none
were working those numbers up the
drought was in this period here and this
part we effectively doubled the refugee
the drought effectively doubled the
refugee population in the serious in the
the cities of Syria so the total urban
population in Syria began at a
13.8 million in 2003 8.9 million in 2002
and climbed to 13.8 million by the time
the war began of those the population
increase would have been about one and a
half million at two and a half percent
birth rate and that was equaled by Iraqi
refugees and Syrian refugees so the thus
it is really hard to prove that the
cities that where these migrants went to
was where the the uprising began but
colloquially that does stand stand up in
the where we know the my greatest cities
where the migrants ended up worse the
cities where the uprising began a lot of
the urban population in syd the decor
urban middle-class population in Syria
was complaining about rural refugees in
Syria inciting this revolt so it
probably played a role the war in Iraq
probably played you know an equally
large role as well and then the ongoing
dynamic of events related to Syria in
the wider region that the evidence is
there that this drought which we have
shown would became more likely because
of climate change was one of the factors
that play a role so finally in East
Africa East Africa is one place in the
world where four decade for a decade or
more now famine and mass starvation and
death is occurring it's not that it's
not that common in the world anymore but
East Africa Somalia southern Sudan and
so on is one place so the observed
precipitation history we have about a
hundred years of rain gauge data in East
Africa that's the bars here this is the
recent drought so in since about the end
of the 1990s there's been a precipitous
decline in precipitation in East Africa
that is unprecedented although there
have been some extended droughts in East
Africa before and then that's from the
rain gauge data this is these are
various satellite products that begin in
these 70s early 80s there's been some
low pass filtering applied that's why
they begin
early 80s and the satellites agree
actually make this decline in
precipitation much more extreme than the
than the rain gauge data does but all
the data indicates that this drought has
has been ongoing and you know one of the
reviewers of this paper said you can you
prove that it really was a drought it's
like do you know I mean it's you know
anyone anyone who's who the IRI has lots
of people who work in this region I mean
there's tons of this is observed it
don't need to know you know you don't
need a weatherman to know which way the
wind blows you don't need a weatherman
to know that this drought has been going
on in East Africa for a long period of
time but anyway there you are and if you
take precipitation within this region
and regressive sea surface temperature
you find again are familiar Pacific
pattern when it's wet in this region you
tend to have this cool Pacific cool
phase of the Pacific decadal variability
if you do that instead of regression you
do that on SST composites so you
composite all the wet years and
composite all to dry the dry years and
do a difference dry- wet again you find
this specific decayed or pattern
interestingly not so much in the Indian
Ocean it seems like the Pacific is the
dominant one here and Brad lion and Dave
DeWitt of the iri recently published two
very nice papers that show that show
this so it seems the general rule is and
the latter part of the the is no
exception the general rule is that
drought in East Africa is tropical
Pacific driven on the other number less
the East African drought is one which is
commonly attributed to climb to climate
change including by my boss Jeff Sachs
the head of the Earth Institute and very
various other people it's always being
invoked as climate changes is the cause
of it but actually it turns out that
climate models predict the East Africa
will get wetter so this is the trend
over the twin over
historical period this black line for
the cement five models and they show it
just getting very very little wetter
whereas this again the bars here are
what actually happened so and then this
is the precipitation trend that has
actually happened from 79 to 2008 from
satellite data there's the East African
drought and this is the signal of the
Pacific decadal variability but cold
temperatures here going forward for this
period out to the future this is what
the cement five models say project will
happen so they project that this region
you can't really see it there but they
do project that it's going to get wetter
there as part of an increased
precipitation in the tropical Pacific
ITCZ so what has happened over the last
three decades is completely opposite to
what the cement five models project
should be happening as a consequence of
climate change so what do you believe in
that case well primarily that difference
is because what's going on what's been
going on in East Africa for the last few
decades is natural variability but the
these couple models first of all the SST
false models so if you just take the
atmosphere models and and put the sea
surface temperature under underneath
them they do this has seen this is from
the seed model from the cement r5
archive they do produce a drying here so
to see Matt 5 ensemble mean is the black
line here so they when you tell them
what the sea surface temperature is they
knew that after the 97 98 it should get
drier there so the atmosphere models are
doing all right in this in this region
and they're saying it gets drier there
because the tropical Pacific get gots
cold so again that's the end of the 97
98 El Nino the shifter too cold estate
at a tropical Pacific as part of the
global precipitation response to that
you have the drying of western North
America is one but drying of Eastern
Africa is another but when you look at
these couple
models they do a terrible job they none
of them reproduce not one of the seam at
five models reproduces that connection
between Pacific decadal variability and
dry in East Africa they just one they
just really sort of don't have Pacific
decadal variability very realistically
to the extent they have any Pacific
decadal variability they do not connect
it to East Africa correctly so the
models just do not the couple GCMs do
not represent this type of behavior and
know that coupled models don't the
couple models don't have this connection
between East Africa and the Pacific
Ocean the the atmosphere models that
just the atmosphere models if you give
them the sea surface temperature history
they correctly can connect the tropical
Pacific to East Africa when you impose
the SST under the atmosphere when you
take that atmosphere model couple and
ocean model with it it's wrong it's
computing it's out so you're just
looking to see whether they get that
type of behavior and they don't it's
partly because they can't make the PDO
but it's also partly this so in in East
Africa there are two there are two
precipitation maximums there is there's
a a big peak in the early part of the
year and a secondary peak in them in in
the fall this is the so that's the bars
of the actual data from rain gauges this
is what the models do when the SST is
imposed they get that kind of right now
if you take the couple GCMs where their
computing their own SSTs and so on they
do this so they actually get a peek here
which is weaker than a second peak which
is way in the end of the year so they're
just the couple GCMs are incorrectly
modeling the seasonal cycle over East
Africa and I would imagine that is one
reason the fact that they cannot get the
mean climate right in this region is one
region reason why they don't get the
variability right
the other reason would be they're not
getting that Pacific decadal variability
right but the fact that they can't get
the mean climate right in this region
makes you really wonder whether their
prediction that it's going to get wetter
in this region is correct because
they're just not living in the right in
the right term climate world this is
this is not the case if you're thinking
about Western North America or northeast
Brazil or something like they're they're
the models can get the seasonal cycles
right and you'd probably have some
confidence in their projections of the
future but in this very very key region
because it's the one region in the world
where hundreds of thousands of people
are dying because of a drought and
starvation it's a politically vulnerable
region it's one where US security forces
are continually paying attention to
because of the relation to international
security this is one plot one place
where these cement five models seem to
do an incredibly bad job and there
making a prediction of the future that
it's going to get wetter Wendy a century
has just got dryer within up to now has
just got dryer so I think probably all
bets are off within that region but you
would not want any of the aid agencies
basing their decisions on the seek the
current state of the cement five models
in that region but apparently they they
are okay I should stop I think this is
the last slide but i just want to point
out if you haven't got the point by now
that there are these global hydro
climate regimes there you know when
you're looking at East Africa and South
America North American northeast Brazil
they tend to go together or out of face
because much of this is being
orchestrated by the Pacific and Atlantic
oceans and it's creating connections
between hemispheres around the
hemispheres into what you could call you
know regimes of hydro climate again Brad
line and Dave DeWitt have a really nice
paper out in 2013 just published that is
a it's a it's about that I think I'll
miss that because they must be overtime
right
yep a little okay I the point of the
point I'll just the point of the
previous slide which I won't show you
because it takes a long time to explain
is that the staccato variability is
really important and it's going to carry
on into the future and much of what we
will experience in the future is going
to be all of what we experience is going
to be some mix of radiatively force
change and the continually evolving
decade or variability now a lot of
people like to say well the radio false
friend how you know it's um is it
significant and there was a couple of
papers by car adesso recently focused on
North America where she claims that you
know there's no statistically
significant precipitation trends that
appear anywhere over North America over
the 21st century I'm probably miss
phrase miss phrasing that but that's
kind of the the implication and they're
looking for like ninety-five percent you
know levels significance then you know
for those of us who actually come out of
a seasonal interannual prediction
environment when we do seasonal
predictions we don't look for
statistical significance when you when
we issue for cars for what precipitation
is going to be for the next the next
season it's presented in terms of
probabilities of tersites you say
there's a sixty percent chance that
precipitation in southwest u.s. this
coming winter will be in the lower
tercel or a thirty percent chance will
be in the middle toes aisle you know
that's how that's that that's the way
that seasonal predictions have done that
may not be statistically significant
that it's considered a useful forecast
and we what I did there was like looking
at well we have this past decade or
variability we know this really matters
we can have history that shows that
those de kado variations matter they
might fall below statistical
significance but they matter so why
don't we look at climate change and try
to relate it to tour styles of the
decade or precipitation decayed or
precipitation when does the radiatively
force change start shifting the
probability of tersites falling in Tudor
size and the basic conclusion is that
like if you are in
ozona New Mexico by the next thur you
know decade or two the probability of
being in the dryer tercel goes from
being a third which is what you'd expect
if it's just continuing natural
variability to like fifty sixty percent
so you know there might not be
statistical significance by Clara desis
standards but by the standards of having
to adapt a decade or variability that is
significant if six of if you can expect
a six of your next winters are going to
be in the lower third of the 20 assists
Oracle distributions 20th century that's
kind of a worrying full cast but that's
what it does say by about 20 20 20 20 30
20 40 you sort of getting to that the
only other point so you know much of
what his global de kado variability that
the white areas i looked at is related
to the pacific and atlantic that what
and we can explain much of that but what
really i find a mystery is some of these
ones like long wedding trends here
northeast North America or South East
South America where we've got these
unexplained very long trends there at
the very very limit of what atmosphere
models can do and are they just you know
unusual atmospheric variability doing
this and it's just unusual or al it's
there really something else going on
there that this that those trends are
saying is that our models do not have
sufficient decade to centennial
variability they should be more is there
some other kind of mode of forcing that
we're missing is some of these
century-long trends related to sort of
coming out of the Little Ice Age could
they even be orbitally forced I mean
it's quite it's possible so I think
that's a sort of an ongoing mystery
that's really worth looking at so I'll
stop there thank you
you